and after 96 yeah this has got to have  been a very now A5 for example is the  movie before this is White's dream to  trade off the isolated Pawn for these  two strong ones right  correct okay so he's gone on an  adventure with his Knight to the edge of  the board  hitting the bishop Bishop is just  probably going to step back to the  square it came from yeah and there we go  you're right and this helps white right  I always thought the idea was to get the  white tonight to this square and he's  going back no Anish don't repeat no it's  happening what what  white is better such a weird white has  an advantage and East just bails out  with a draw what is that about is that  over is that true firmed he dropped back  his Knight black moved his Bishop he  moved his Knight the bishop went back  and they repeated This Dance  objectively he knows he was better I  think he's just playing on the  tournament standings Anisha Gary  oh yes is this anisha's big problem in  top chess